les profs s'étaient mobilisés
aujourd'hui contre les suppressions de
postes des suppressions de postes dans
les collèges et lycées les suppressions
de postes au sein de l'éducation
nationale de situations penser la même
chose à chaque rentrée depuis la fin des
années 90 les suppressions de postes
dans l'éducation nationale et les
premières traquer sont souvent les mêmes
les professeurs de collèges et de lycées
des annonces faites par les ministres
avec plus ou moins de tact comparaison
bestial pour claude allègre claude
allègre donne le ton le 24 juin 97 dans
les colonnes du journal le monde
il annonce son intention de dégraisser
le mammouth style plus compatissant en
2007 où xavier darcos tente l'annnonce
du ce n'est pas si grave
je rappelle que c'est 0,8 pour cent de
l'ensemble de nos effectifs c'est un
chiffre qui n'est pas négligeable mais
tout de même lorsqu'on était 100 et
qu'on devient 99 et des poussières
on arrive tout de même à faire la même
chose les raisons invoquées de ces
suppressions de postes sont à chaque
fois les mêmes une baisse de la
démographie des collégiens et lycéens
mais aussi et surtout le besoin de faire
des économies
à chaque fois les professeurs les
parents d'élèves et les élèves eux mêmes
dénoncent les conséquences de ces profs
en moins on a des options qui sont
partis qui parque les options en
plastique les options mat
donc voilà plus ça va et mon as tu un
haut niveau d'éducation et ça c'est pas
c'est pas acceptable
pourtant les suppressions de postes
continuent si en 2000 les collèges et
lycées publics comptait plus de 423 1000
professeurs ils étaient près de 43 mille
de moins en 2013
l'ensemble de ces dispositions
manifestement n'a qu'une seule finalité
c'est de faire encore une fois des
économies budgétaires sur le dos de
l'éducation nationale alors que
peut-être il est d'autres lieux où l'on
pourrait le faire que l'avenir de la
jeunesse la saignée dénoncée par la
gauche s'arrête pendant le quinquennat
de françois hollande et le nombre de
professeurs du secondaire reprend des
couleurs
mais deux
les professeurs sont la cible des
économies budgétaires jean michel
blanquer a annoncé la suppression de
2650 postes à la rentrée 2010 9
pourtant d'après les prévisions
réalisées par le ministère de
l'éducation nationale
le nombre d'élèves du secondaire va
augmenter d'ici 2022
[Musique]